bonsoir françois xavier gicquel merci
d'être avec nous alors on le voit
évidemment la crise est partout
malheureusement au liban même dans les
écoles le seul endroit qu'il restait
finalement aux enfants pour s'épanouir
il est important d'agir urgemment la
situation est très critique
oui je pense que votre reportage a bien
mis en exergue des réalités biais de
cette crise qui sont en effet en fait
une crise globale qui voit de multiples
épisodes se succéder déjà en effet on a
une crise politique qui n'est pas
nouvelle au liban qui date déjà depuis
leurs années un gouvernement s'était
formée après déjà de grandes difficultés
gouvernement qui est tombé avec
l'explosion de beyrouth mais également
une crise économique du fait notamment
déchéance non tenues les habits du fmi
qui se sont ensuite aggravé avec
l'explosion avait dans un premier temps
l'apparition du corona virus qui a qui a
encore plus enfoncé le clou dans cette
société qui était meurtri qui ne voyait
plus le bout du tunnel qui voyait plus
haut elle allait où les enfants étaient
déjà déscolarisé depuis de nombreux mois
puis cette explosion du port de beyrouth
qui a représenté une véritable crise à
la fois politiques mais aussi
économiques
c'est à dire que on a eu à la fois une
perte de comptes de confiance encore
plus poussée envers les autorités
politiques
ce que tout le monde pensait qu'il
n'était pas possible cc réaliser puisque
puisque l'explosion du port de beyrouth
a rêvé leed
voilà deux
profonde incompétence des autorités est
peut-être un manque de souveraineté des
autorités sur la zone portuaire de
beyrouth un climat de rivalité entre
différentes factions libre ce qui était
extrêmement compliqué surtout qui a
plongé le pays dans une crise économique
encore plus grave puisque comme vous
savez le port de beyrouth est un des
poumons économiques du liban et surtout
de l'explosion s'est produite au coeur
de beyrouth
qui est réellement la zone économique
principal du libre
pardonnez-moi françois xavier gicquel
vous êtes directeur des opérations de
sos chrétiens d'orient précisément les
chrétiens d'orient qu'il y avait un rôle
important notamment dans la protection
de ses enfants
c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui ils ont
une meilleure marge de manoeuvre est
bien évidemment moins élevé alors en
fait pas nécessairement parce que
l'enseignement aux chrétiens au liban
est extrêmement important puisque c'est
ses traits réellement l'enseignement de
plus haut niveau qui existe au liban et
surtout qui accueille toutes les
communautés composant la mosaïque
libanaise est aujourd'hui avec cette
crise financière sans précédent
ces écoles ferment pour différentes
raisons déjà parce que les parents ne
peuvent plus payer les frais de
scolarité et ses écoles donc se
retrouvent en difficulté financière mais
également ne peuvent plus se fournir à
l'international puisque la livre
libanaise ne permet pas d'acheter sur le
marché international soumis au dollar et
donc ces écoles sont en effet en
difficulté et par la difficulté de ces
écoles chrétiennes qui sont
véritablement le creuset de
civilisations commune du peuple libanais
qu'ils soient chrétiens
quelles que soient les différences entre
entre chaque chrétien musulman chiite
sont musulmans sunnites druzes
en fait ces écoles ne sont plus en
mesure ou ne vont plus être en mesure
d'effectuer leur leurs oeuvres de
rassemblement et d'éducation du peuple
libanais dans son intégralité et en fait
c'est tout le vivre ensemble à la
libanaise qui est menacée demain par la
remise en cause de cet enseignement
chrétiens libanais gouvernement ne fait
rien sur ce plan parce qu'on
nous entend et on voit là l'urgence d'un
tel problème et surtout les concessions
conséquences désastreuses déjà
aujourd'hui il ya plus qu il ya plus de
gouvernement pour commencer est
également voilà comme vous voit sur vos
images actuellement des manifestations
monstrueux dans les rues de beyrouth
plusieurs plusieurs ministères ont été
incendiés la situation est extrêmement
tendue à tripoli c'est la maison du
gouverneur qui a été attaqué vraiment il
y a fait des mesures coville qui empêche
les gens de travailler au quotidien
du fait de la situation économique en
règle générale de la situation politique
il y avait une instabilité tel qui
naquit n'a pas existé depuis la guerre
civile qu'il est très difficile de
travailler au niveau national sur des
enjeux tels que l'éducation
le gouvernement français vient jean yves
le drian avait annoncé qu'il avait vu
venir en aide aux écoles libanaises le
contrat n'a pas été remplie pour
l'instant pour la majorité des écoles
qui attendent toujours une aide à ce
niveau là et c'est pour ça qu'elle
souhaite chrétiens d'orient s'est engagé
pour soutenir l'éducation des écoles
chrétiennes libanaises pour garantir un
futur à ses enfants et garantir le
système de vivre ensemble la libanaise
dans les années à venir
aujourd'hui clairement qu'ils vous
aident alors nous nous nous avons cent
mille donateurs privés majoritairement
des familles des individualités qui nous
financent de 2 20 euros par mois jusqu'à
jusqu'à plusieurs évidemment aux
milliers d'euros et c'est grâce à ça que
au travail de huit pays nous réussissons
à mener nos projets particulièrement
liban aujourd'hui où nous soutenons à la
fois des des individualités en fait des
dizaines et des dizaines de familles qui
ont besoin d'être pour payer leurs frais
de scolarité et donc que nous soutenons
de manière individuelle mais aussi des
institutions que nous soutenons comme
voilà dans le sud par exemple près de
saïda l'école saint-nicolas
nous nous fournissons de mai dernier
pour près de 200 enfants à notre homme
de la békaa car dans l'est du pays
nous nous avons financé également une
école à hauteur de 30 mille dollars et à
beyrouth ce sont deux écoles arméniennes
que nous aidons pour les frais de
scolarité pour financer à spa était de
plusieurs dizaines d'enfants et cette
aide va s'accroître dans les mois à
venir pour vraiment nous saisir de ce
sujet crucial encore une fois pour
l'avenir du liban
merci beaucoup françois xavier gicquel
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france